hello internet welcome to film
theory reaction our first one
first film theory reaction from the film
theory
very excited uh this one is thor will
destroy
the mcu marvel phase five excited check
this out i've seen
so many film theory videos and way more
than game theory
uh for obvious reasons um and then yeah
after the reaction
i guess we'll talk about what we agree
with maybe add a little bit to the
conversation
who knows let's watch this stuff man
[Music]
come out thanos i know you're hiding in
there
thanos was but a minor nuisance compared
to me child
i am the mcu's greatest enemy galactus
mafisto the one below all no
corporate expectations huh hey
that's yeah yes crap battle
hello internet welcome to film theory
loosely but about future motion pictures
ever since the global pandemic thrust
trolls world tour into a default
oscar nod but i gotta say there is some
is that for real
news to all of this down time to hear
about that
details can now be spent combing over
the enormous backlog
of comic books that have been piling up
over the last few years as loyal fans
know some of my best predictions that
comes from comic book plots first and in
secret empire numbers
but what's important here is that black
widow has shown that she's willing to
sacrifice herself to stop the worst
possible timelines from playing out but
today i'm going deeper
they got it right so this one's gonna be
right formerly the head marvel movie guy
is now just the head marvel guy guy
he is now the creative director in
charge of everything that marvel
legally controls i am feige everything
the light touches
everything right unprecedented power
comes unprecedented responsibility
fundy is taking control of marvel at its
peak
crossover event in history already
behind him a lot of fans are wondering
where it all goes next
well loyal theorists i'm here today
disney plus
massive going forward a crossover event
to make end game and into the
spider-verse seem like small potatoes
just like the infinity war saga was
ultimately building to a climactic
battle against thanos i'm now convinced
that kevin feige is building this next
story arc into a battle that'll merge
the marvel multiverse
yes it needs to be established that
marvel has something of a loosely
connected multiverse going
there's a long history of numbering
universes in marvel especially in the
comics with the universe numbered 616
being the primary marvel universe say
what you will about dc's movies but at
the very least they have a common
decency to start with universe 1.
also just make matters even more
confusing rather than calling it
universe 6.6 as would make total sense
it almost always is designated by earth
earth
means that even if you're talking about
out in space activities you're still
referring to the whole thing as the
earth
616 yeah but even more and more
confusingly
part of a multiverse that has been
reborn multiple times
in total there have been seven
multiverse renewals during the entire
history of the marvel multiverse where
an old multiverse completely dies out
only to be replaced by a new one
in other words marvel comics exists in a
multi multiverse
so earth 616 is the main timeline but
there are plenty of other fun little
offshoots plenty of others earth 90214
is marvel noir where daredevil iron man
spiderman and the x-men game
1920s
101001 is the universal id for the
marvel anime yeah the marvel
anime 90s animated shows of both
x-men and spider-man coming in and earth
65 is the universal id for spider-man
marvel's spider instead of peter parker
and goes on to become a spider woman
while peter parker turns himself into
the lizard in an attempt to be special
like her
yes this is the same thing when stacy
who gets pulled through
into the spider verse which itself takes
place in earth 1610
the mcu was given the designation of
1999
apparently named after the year kevin
feige started producing the x-men movie
plus
just some more nines in there to sound
cool however with avengers endgame the
mcu is now canonically not taking place
in a single universe anymore
as discussed by hulk and the ancient one
the infinity stones
create what you experience as the flow
of time
remove one of the stones and that close
splits
now this may benefit your reality but my
new one
not so much wait hold on here quick
sidebar in the movie thanos admits to
destroying the infinity stones the
things that we just heard
create the flow of time to talk about
yourself who said he reduced them to
atoms at the very least we've witnessed
multiple different realities
in the mcu on the big screen which
technically
matters can't be destroyed whatever
redistributed
[Music]
because on patreon i'm on season four
come watch along with me again
just a second
stop minus thanos was attacked by a
completely
unrelated event involving the villain
graviton resulting in the near
extinction of all humanity so they go
back in time with the monolith stopping
him and creating a
second major mcu-related timeline since
then they've been going gung-ho with
time travel because
i can't believe i'm even going to try to
explain this plot but here we go
the alien civilization of super
intelligent computers lose their home
world so they kidnap the shield
scientists they believe solve time
travel and ask them to build a new time
travel machine so that they can save
their home planet in the past
they somehow managed to build it which
the aliens then used to go back in time
to stop shield from being made so they
could invade earth more easily which
actually works so the shield scientists
managed to take all the main characters
back to a good timeline sacrificing the
one which season 7 takes place
season 7 is hilarious that's hard to
keep up with at least
60 sure that the writers are in on the
joke in any case agents of shield has
taken place in no
fewer than three distinct timelines
again connected canonically via the mcu
so the mcu is in and of itself a
multi-purpose
multi-version also while i'm thinking
about it who needs a time stone or for
that matter who needs to beg tony stark
to invent time travel when your shield
pals already have themselves a time
machine
captain america if you just need a bit
more attention to the little guys in
your canonically related tv spin-off
series you would have saved yourself
a lot yeah why am i talking about that
as well it seems that the next big step
for the mcu will be combining
all the different multiverses into one
from the movies of course but also from
the tv shows
and also from the comics in 2015 marvel
destroyed the comics multiverse in their
second secret wars event
long story short this plotline had
earths from different universes
colliding destroying their entire
universe in the process
in an unusual turn of events the heroes
ultimately failed to save the multiverse
pieces of different universes got
smashed together in an
area beyond time and space called battle
world before things were eventually
reset into the eighth
and current iteration but here's the
thing marvel used this
massive event not only to reset but to
massively
rework the marvel continuity they took
the chance to end
the ultimate line of comics that moved
popular characters like miles morales
over
into the main 616 continuity this helped
clean up marvel history while not
totally rewriting all of the characters
the idea was that new readers wouldn't
have to know the entire history of the
marvel universe just to get into a new
book but
long time readers didn't have to abandon
everything
that they do and loved about their
all-time favorites so they're gonna do
exactly
that again for a multiverse ending event
of its own
remember marvel through the next few
phases needs to find a way to stop
end game the
russo talking about the next avengers
quote it would be the biggest movie you
could possibly imagine
so that's what really excites us about
the story the ambition of it
is even bigger than the ambition of the
infinity saga before i completely write
that off as insane remember
into the spider-verse introduce the
world to the idea of not just a
multiversal superhero movie but a
multiverse where characters could
operate by wildly different rules and
based on its box office and critical
success you can bet marvel
and crimson notes from that movie the
latest rumors burning up the internet
all seemed to indicate that toby maguire
from the 2000's era spider-man trilogy
and andrew garfield of the amazing
spider-man movies
are both going to appear as alternate
universe spideys in the next
mcu spider-man outing these casting
decisions are still
definitely rumors but when asked
directly about them they simply stated
that quote
those rumored castings were not
confirmed makes it sound a lot less like
it's not happening and more like they're
still in contract negotiations yeah
you have agents of shield outright
creating teams of secret warriors
preparing for some
secret war of their own some battles
need shots please
i think i've seen that quick
both of the latest two thor stories thor
has been worried about the
end of his universe in the comic king
thor a future
thor from earth11412 worries about the
coming
all black which is the end of his
universe in the form of all black
everything and his necro sword from that
series but now the universe is a
trembling
invalid collapsing it upon itself and
wheezing its last
soon there will only be entropy and
inertia of
that focused around a similar malicious
forks the black winter
the star plague the great black winter
it is
coming yeah it's winter coming for you
thor don't worry history proves true
it's not as bad as they make it out
escalation of bad guys
the black winter killed the universe
before ours thor
as galactus devours worlds the winter
comes for realities
just to showcase exactly how much of a
bad guy the black winter really
is they showed him literally destroying
the dc
universe which gotta admit it's just
what
it's revealed that the black winter has
destroyed the entire multiverse before
causing the end of the sixth incarnation
of the universe he is such a bad dude
that even galactus who was the sole
survivor of the last multiverse
is afraid of him galactus claims that
him the black winter
looks like thor and would you know it
but in the king thor comic we learned
that thor
might actually be the one to cause the
end of the universe as they say there
all hail for the end father no
the black winter himself calls thor the
end god
no to me one of the most interesting
bits from the comics is this line
also from that recently released king
thor oh wow would they go
that path remember how this whole saga
began they wouldn't do that
the war of the realms the cosmic god cop
cases
jim foster for those who don't remember
is natalie portman's character from the
first two thor movies and ever so
briefly an endgame
when phase four was announced at last
year's comic con natalie portman took
the stage and triumphantly hoisted
mjolnir above her head
clearly signaling the coming of jane
foster's
thor in the upcoming thor love and
thunder so
that's one pretty solidly off that
checklist
because of the realms also kind of
happened in the mcu during the events of
thor
ii i bet you forgot about this the war
of the rings is actually a comic plot
in the immediate aftermath of thor 2 but
dealt with similarities
such as malacath's attempt to destroy
everything so that is
two off of that bucket list before the
end of the universe
the cosmic god cop cases haven't
happened yet but it's
likely the loki series will actually
deal with these
yes exactly what it sounds like they are
a police force for god
which honestly sounds like the sort of
thing that would fit really well in a
show about a renegade god
loki i've heard this theory before
history which is exactly how that disney
plus loki series is being described and
then finally there's mangog a villain
that's not really worth explaining in
detail here but was trapped beneath
asgard in the comics so he's probably
still safely contained under the
oh gosh
list before the end of days comes to the
marvel multiverse
so long and short of it all is this the
comics are already setting up for
another multiversal end
they've introduced black winter a threat
that's destroyed the multiverse before
and it's starting to threaten marvel's
biggest heroes on its own this would
normally be the start of a huge comic
crossover event but
given the recent events at marvel i
think it's actually setting up for
something
even bigger i know i'm not comic book
theory but i think there's
a lot of hints that kevin feige you do a
lot of comic books
as cco he's already had thor tackle the
end of the universe multiple
times in the comics and consider this
marvel studios
is acting more like a comics company
today than it ever has
in movies they have disney plus
spin-offs they have animated spin-offs
thor even crossed over into fortnight in
a canonical tie-in
and no that is not just a theory
according to marvel comics editor that
was canonical
we had a lot of great creative
discussions between
games about where our storylines would
cross over naturally but seeing how
prime a target the fortnite island would
be for galactus who donnie cates has
already been exploring in his thor
series set the whole thing in motion
just like with the comics
storylines will stick around and some
won't but after the next few phases
you'll need a way to bring it
all back together to keep the characters
that work to lose the ones that don't
all into one
timeline that the average movie goer can
still watch and appreciate
and that is why i think a multiversal
threat and ultimate collapse
is on the horizon just like thanos was
all throughout the infinity saga
not this phase wow but just like with
thanos
this is hard to describe the
[Music]
all universe with thor but hey
that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
wow dang dude that was that's
unboxing that's a lot to absorb it's
compelling
crap i really really love this video
i watch film theory more than i watch
game theory reflecting on it and brief
moments
it has me thinking and i'm not sure if
it's actually stated in this video
because there's
talking about collapsing the timelines
and such and kind of having to start so
that way
we can have like as the series keeps
going
the mcu itself that way average
moviegoers can still keep watching it i
mean i'm
like for the longest time us film lovers
have been talking
plenty about man 10 20 years from now i
mean our audience is gonna be able to
keep up with
all of this right so so it makes sense
to take it in this direction i'm also
wondering though and this is where i i'm
not sure if
matpat brought this up in the video is
kevin feige
also now that he's in charge of marvel
comics as well
is he trying to establish this in a way
get it to a point
where it's all connected comics shows
movies animated series all that is he
trying to get it to
that point where you can just go that's
from a different multiverse that's a
different earth
that's it but it's at the end of the day
the movies themselves are directly
connected to the comics that are not
just adaptations yeah like they're
trying to establish a
a multiverse of literal media where the
characters in their
different iterations are consistent and
travel back and forth
it's an interesting idea and i mean he
did touch that idea that
marvel now more than ever resembles in
its film department
a comics company in their approach given
that i don't think there's any reason to
stop them from continuing down that line
i could totally see this being a
tangible theory
i could see feige doing that i could
absolutely
that would make people want to read
comics even more too
because you know it's weird as much as
there's been a boom in the comic book
movie industry there's been
hasn't been much of a boom with comics
themselves
and so this would allow for this the
sales of that to go
up as well if people are like oh but
these are directly connected to the
movies in some way now too you know the
title of this video
does have you hooked in a way of somehow
thor is going to be a villainous in
a certain sense i'm kind of wondering
though there's been a lot of rumors
speculating
about how and it's i'm surprised it
doesn't really touch on like multiverse
of madness here in this video i mean you
get like a moment of doctor strange
everyone's usually capitalizing on one
division of multiverse of madness i
don't really know if going to
secret wars for the next avengers movie
would be the right
call still i definitely find this theory
very palpable i do think that
that will happen one day especially the
way this has been pitched and packaged
like yeah i think doing this condensing
a multiverse
i love the way how it was stated here
that way people who have been following
it won't feel like that's all being
ignored
and then average moviegoers can still
continue to watch it or if you're a new
viewer right i love that idea but
there's still some other big baddies i
think we gotta get to
in this video they say galactus is
destroyer of worlds and black winter
is destroyer of realities and i think if
you go to black
winter before you get to galactus
yeah yeah who go and galactus fears
black winter especially given that
detail yeah i'm like oh i think you got
to do your next crossover it wouldn't be
as good as
that right it wouldn't be as good if you
brought him galactus after
in a reset universe yeah yeah yeah but i
think especially with including the
the x-men and fantastic four into the
equation now they're gonna want to do
something
that is akin to the resemblance of
secret wars and the collapsing of the
of the universes and such there's
obviously been hints so far
already multiverse madness one division
end game already does have
a crossover of multiverses and then like
like they said here we're having loki
and i love the idea too
there were four thor comics that were
listening specifically i love the
concept
that two of them are already being taken
care of that we know of the fourth one
we'll see but the third one god cop
that's really neat if
that really is what's happening in the
loki show because loki is a part of the
thor movies the thor
world so you can take care of it there
and then maybe loki can come back into
the equation and it all affects it this
is one of those things that sounds
confusing and difficult to digest
now but i think as we watch it play out
it'll make
sense yeah absolutely because i think if
they want to do something like this it
makes sense to have
one of your core original avengers be
sort of at the heart of that
and it also makes me wonder what the
future structurally of the mcu is going
to look like
because you know in going with that
again likeness to the comic books world
it's like with the uh
infinity saga we culminated in one huge
team-up crossover and it makes absolute
sense to me
to culminate again in some kind of
multiverse crossover of sorts but what
makes me curious is
how many phases is this going to be
realized
right because the infinity saga is three
phases worth now does this need to be
three phases not necessarily but i think
with a multiverse there's certainly
enough to explore and enough new
characters that we're obviously waiting
to see on screen
that they could take their time it's
like yeah i don't want the next avengers
movie to be secret wars unless they wait
three phases to make a new avengers
movie or something like that it
definitely seems like the logical thing
on the horizon it mainly just makes me
curious about how the structure is going
to come across i mean we'll see
but also it had me kind of thinking too
when they're talking about king
thor and black winter and all that and
how you know
thor the end god and all these things
that moment in infinity war of how he
should have gone for
the head i'm wondering if in some way
like as i was used as a character motive
that segued into end game
purposeful to get the snap and all those
things in some ways i feel like
the the the maybe the possible
conception of thor being the end god or
aiding that in some way
could be reflected symbolically to a
certain extent
in that moment of not having gone for
the head yeah
i could see it i mean and and it's not
outside the realm for them to pull
little details like that for
significance they're right under your
nose
i'm just using that to aid in the
conversation you hear that yeah that
this all seems very likely
in some shape or another this has to
happen
it's the only way it could really make
sense yeah i think they just need to
give us enough time to enjoy the
multiverse
before crashing it down yeah yeah yeah
we need we need to still slowly get
there but undoubtedly i feel like this
is going to come true in some fashion
all right guys well what do you think
about this theory subscribe to film
theory if you haven't done so already i
love the channel i've seen
binge many videos before is our first
reaction to film theory though subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button
last but not least
tyler hey you gotta shout out tyler hey
when you're talking about thor
because without a doubt if there's
anyone on our patreon page
if you asked me directly who would you
cast from your patreon
to play thor it's tyler hague i'm not
just saying that because it's your shout
out buddy you're a nordic god
you have that look that could embody it
you got the build you got the beard now
if you could just have your
voice go a little bit deeper yeah then
you would definitely have it but you
have this imposing quality
yet the marvel thor maybe not the actual
norse god thor but you got the marvel
author
yeah like oh i could actually i feel
safe with this guy
at the right time yeah exactly so buddy
i know you got your ps5 in coming
can't wait to hear your feedback on it
and i can't wait to talk more games with
you later on
i hope you're doing well hope you're
being safe out there right now
in wisconsin and i'll say
theory and also uh yeah i don't know
there's no also be safe
love you man hope you're being safe
[Music]